all right so Shania is gonna be on the
show tonight to promote her show real
hunter yes did you see the show she's
great I'm mad about it why are you mad
about
I started since we have started this
show think of the spin-offs American
Idol started after The Voice star search
started after the voice now whatever
this thing is and eyes doing we've
started it all
we started it all the theory cuz the
streets are talking and they say if
Shania were to ever come on the voice
she may be the country star that could
take all the country singers from this
one what do you think it's my boy that's
right okay we haven't talked to you
since you had to give up your crown as
the sexiest man alive are you alright
how are you can I be honest I feel like
when when I gave up my crown sexy ended
it just ended in the world so it's until
I get get it back it doesn't exist
anymore I'm sure this new guys a nice
guy is great guys I mean I don't get I
don't see it myself I'm really the only
person I've ever seen it
he doesn't have this how can you be sexy
with that one of these huh where do you
keep your sexy if you don't have this
[Music]